welcome back to New rockstars I'm Anna
Manson and we are back with the plumber
baby because despite my original Super
Mario Brothers movie video having as
many Easter eggs as it did there were
still a ton that didn't make the cut cut
it out sometimes things are cut for time
sometimes things seem too obvious or
there's not enough evidence to support
something and sometimes things are too
hard to make out all right just miss
things upon first viewing after all the
first video was written after I'd only
seen it twice in theaters but now the
Super Mario Bros movie is officially
available online and I can go frame by
frame to get all those little leggies
I'm not covering the over 130 songs and
hundreds of sound effects and game moves
though you'll have to deal with the ones
I mentioned in the previous video I have
a limited sanity also secret invasion is
here be sure to tune in to new rockstars
every Wednesday for a secret Invasion
breakdown and there's even more secret
amazing discussion on our newest channel
the break room that show is filled with
conspiracies research walls and more
crazy details and we'll be breaking it
all down on new rockstars and the break
room but starting with the first scene
one of the things I didn't get to
mention in the previous video is the
insane amount of crossover in the voice
cast between this movie and Teen Titans
Go which starts with comic being voiced
by Kevin Michael Richardson who also
voiced Trigon and this amount of
crossover makes sense since the creator
of Teen Titans Go Michael jelinek and
Aaron Horvath directed this movie this
led to the crossover casting of the
voices for the penguin King Mario's Mom
Uncle Arthur the toad General the Koopa
General and several of the additional
voices in the movie hopping into the
diner let's take a closer look at this
commercial namely the map looking at the
points on the map of course we have
punch out and burger Castle to represent
Punch-Out Pizzeria and Castle burger
which I don't know why they flipped the
name so that's so confusing there's also
a mushroom planet in Red Hill which I
believe are Sonic references as mushroom
planet is in the second Sonic movie and
the proximity of Red Hill makes me think
that it's a parody of Green Hill Zone
although it could also be referring to
the capsule-shaped hills seen throughout
the Mushroom Kingdom since we see in
Super Mario run that they're simply
called the color of the Hill they are
Point Beach might just be like how many
points you have in a game volley Beach
is possibly a nod to beach volleyball
being seen in sub Nintendo games
Greenwood might be a reference to
Growing Greenwood and new Super Mario
Bros Wii or Greenwood Village in Diddy
Kong Racing Sunset possibly referring to
Sunset Wilds in Mario Kart green shell
being another Mario Kart nod Marshland
potentially calling back to the
soundtrack song from Zelda Majora's Mask
and bakery being maybe one of these
bakeries I don't know the other ones I
can make out but I'm not sure if they're
direct references to anything in
particular are Marsh Hill big tower
saluder Fame Hill arders Short city and
Scio Hill for streets I can make out Red
Hill Street which we touched on before
tiny Avenue and big street avenue which
may be a not a tiny huge Island from
Super Mario 64. 87th Street potentially
referring to 1987 in which several huge
name games came out such as Metroid Kid
Icarus and The Legend of Zelda 74th
Street which if it's referencing the
year 1974 is when the light gun game
wild gunman was released link Street and
Wolf Street likely tied together by
Zelda Twilight Princess Mansion Street a
non-to Luigi's Mansion Hollis Street
likely a nod to Martin Hollis a former
video game designer who started at rare
in 1993 and eventually directed
GoldenEye 007 Hanford Avenue in 1889th
Street a reference to the hanafuda
playing cards released upon Nintendo's
founding in 1889 and we can actually see
hanafuda company on the lock cards ad at
the end of the movie which is why
there's also a lot card Street on the
map now it's a commonly held belief that
Nintendo roughly translates to leave
luck to Heaven which might explain the
connection however this has never
officially been verified and there's
even some evidence that points to this
being unlikely given the context but for
that I'll point you to a great Kotaku
article I found where you can read about
it either way luck cards might be in
reference to the playing cards but it's
possible it might be a reference to
something else like the card Flip Game
in Super Mario Brothers 3 which requires
some level of luck couple other little
dates we left out last time were this
Luigi's mansion-esque pose they strike
and while the faces on the dollar signs
are conveniently covered in this shot
you can see that I think it's supposed
to be the same presidents as on our
money though they have 30 cent coins as
well and you know what in this video
we're laying it all on the table even
things that aren't 100 solved so the TV
brand is p Char Vision an acronym we
also see later on the news so it seems
intentional but I don't know why that
acronym speaking of news the Chiron
along the bottom has news headlines
stolen vegetables recovered by Ice
Climbers a clear ice climber's reference
and police respond to disturbance near
Hogan's alley Hogan's alley being an NES
game later on in the news we talked
about the crab headline and Wave Race
reference in the last video but we also
get a headline ending in detect signals
in star system FS 176 a Metroid
reference and the very first part of a
headline reading vwa check referring to
the video wrestling Association in NES
pro wrestling also the logo for this
news channel matches the mktv logo for
Mario Kart and before we head out of the
diner there's a very cute Dash pepper
from Super Mario Galaxy 2 on their hot
sauce bottles moving outside Mario's got
an m on his keychain and his truck is a
sticker similar to the official Nintendo
seal of quality the grocer has a flyer
from Melody perhaps a reference to
pianist Melody pianissima from Luigi's
Mansion a newspaper Mario pass is called
The Daily 8-bit has the headline the
mustache is back and although we call
that the fact that Castle burger was
shaped like a castle at the end of the
section meant to represent level one one
we forgot to mention the star at the
quote unquote end of the level two
though getting a star at the end of
level is more Super Mario 64. heading
into the couple's apartment this
freaking Place holds two out of three of
the biggest question marks that I have
not been able to stop thinking about
since I first saw the movie first the
paintings have a signature that begins
with t and ends in P I but it doesn't
seem to be the pun of the name of a
famous artist there's no famous artist I
can find with a last name that starts
with t and ends with pi there's no one
who worked on the movie with those
letters I even checked the people who
worked on Super Mario Bros 3 since I
believe the paintings are of the
background panels from that game topi is
an enemy in Ice Climbers but that's
nothing that's nothing who is this the
other name that kills me is the dog
being named Francis sure Francis is the
name of the chameleon in Super Paper
Mario but that can't be all there is to
it I checked if it was the name of one
of the crew members pets kids spouses
couldn't find anything it's so specific
though it's ruining my life moving on so
I can lower my blood pressure many of
the books this couple has as fittingly
artsy fartsy like this book just titled
architecture but the level of meta with
these titles is great they have books
titled none more and nothing a book with
an m on it perhaps for Mario at a four
book series titled one quarter book they
also have a book series that has red
magenta blue yellow and green squares
which match up to the main components of
additive color mixing that is used for
screens and say of video games the only
color missing is cyan but there also
seems to seems to be a book missing from
the Shelf further down they also have a
book that has red green and blue squares
the primary colors of light Mario
Luigi's house suffered the brunt of the
most cut for time Easter eggs just
because there's so much in here firstly
when they come in the AO is a reference
to Luigi's voice actor Charlie Day's
character on it's always sunny who
commonly enters the room with an
some of the things around the room that
we didn't point out last time are the
family portraits up on the wall the
notable ones being Mario striking a post
from Mario Tennis Aces and baby Mario
and Luigi riding in the same little cart
a la devil Dash style they also have a
sports pennant for Little Mac and one
for golf a nod to yet another sport that
Mario has played and that pennant says
Slugger mate at first I thought it said
Slugger butts and now I'm not sure what
I'm gonna do with the 200 ghost Slugger
butt shirts I had printed but we see the
name again later in Mario's room on a
poster that says sluggermate vs Ultra
machine Ultra machine being a toy
released in Japan by Nintendo in 1967
which was released in other countries
under the name Slugger mate on the
bookshelf so we can see they have a
statuette that gives me major Precious
Moments flashbacks some fantasy books
like this fairy tale book and Little Red
Riding Hood and some figurines that I
can't quite place but the feather in
this one's hair looks a little like a
Cape Feather on the dinner table there's
a bottle of vinegar that has the chef
from the DS game personal trainer
cooking on it and later on they also
have orange juice with a character that
gives me grubba from Paper Mario the
Thousand Year Door Vibes or just just a
blue Spike and the character on the
maple syrup bottle looks to maybe be the
Burger Time Chef or more obscurely maybe
even Chef Pierre from the game out to
lunch for dinner the family's eating
some classic Italian dishes including a
mushroom carbonara a salad with red
onion black olives and a vinaigrette and
minestrone soup well the main joke of
Uncle Tony snatching the salad bowl out
of Luigi's hands is that he keeps taking
Luigi's food throughout the scene before
he can eat it an interesting note is
that this may double as an
acknowledgment that in Italy you never
start with a salad it is almost always a
later course or served alongside a
courses aside making it okay for the
uncle to have it with his spaghetti but
not as Luigi's first helping Uncle Tony
is also the one who asked them what's
with the white gloves and Mario says you
gotta have a trademark and stand out
Shigeru Miyamoto said in an interview
that he gave Mario gloves to stand out
from his clothes and make his movements
easier to spot when he jumps while we
pointed out a lot of the memorabilia in
Mario's room last time there's a whole
lot more to mention we could see a
baseball on the ground as an homage
tomorrow's baseball history and oddly
enough a football helmet which is one of
the the only massively popular sports
that hasn't been made into a Mario game
he also has a drawing mannequin and I'm
really hoping this artistic possession
is an Ode to Mario Paint which I still
hold in my heart to this day and other
QD strikes we didn't get to last time
are a calendar with an excite bite
picture a Nintendo logo sticker on his
TV a box with Galaxy written on it and
not just Super Mario Galaxy and a whole
lot of pipes and tools including a box
saying pipeco looking at his bulletin
board a little more closely we can see
postcards that have their truck logo a
letter that has the same red white and
blue border also seen in the kitchen
reminiscent of the letters in Super
Mario Galaxy 2 and drawings of them as
adults and babies that resemble the
Mario Kart Wii cover before we hop into
the Mushroom Kingdom we pointed out how
the level one two sign in the sewers was
a Super Mario Brothers reference but I
also saw a few people online speculating
that the design of the sign is based off
of the sign in Nintendo's original
headquarters in Kyoto and while not one
for one I thought the resemblance was
interesting but let's get stuck through
that clear pipe in Cloud world that
resembles Super Mario 3D World and land
in the Mushroom Kingdom with Mario we're
surrounded by cheap cheap Bram balls
bitty Buds and little birds yes they're
canonically called little birds you can
also see some fortresses in the
background surrounding the red brick
structure that Mario shot out of and we
pointed this out in a previous video but
I want to stress again the symbolism
behind the structure where Mario crosses
from The Real World to the Mushroom
Kingdom being made of realistic red
brick which merges the human world and
the red bricks we know from the games
and having an archway which is a common
symbol of transition and change in media
that's great design folks also
previously mentioned in one of our
trailer breakdowns toad warning Mario
not to touch the blue mushroom or he'll
die before correcting himself is likely
a joke that he's mistaking it for a
poison mushroom which in the games are
purple touching mace with Luigi The
Fortress he runs to has the same shape
as the fortresses on the world map in
Super Mario World and the inside has a
checkered flooring and Center staircase
like Bowser's Castle and Paper Mario
origami King though fortresses have also
had a checkered floors in Super Mario
Bros 3 and Super Mario All-Stars when
Luigi has a flashback you can see a
yellow truck with a red ladder which is
the same design as the brothers truck
when they're older and then there's this
kid now this kid is the last giant
mystery to me and I have been thinking
about it since I first saw the movie and
I will be thinking about this on my
deathbed I will be in the ground
annoying worms with my conspiracy
theories but this kid's design is so
specific and yet for the life of me I
cannot figure out who it's supposed to
be I have three theories but to be
honest none are airtight the first and
strongest one to me is that this kid is
just supposed to match the color scheme
of the bully enemy from the Mario games
which attracts to me because he's a
bully the second is that he's maybe just
supposed to give off Koopaling Vibes
with a green and yellow in the shades
and then lastly someone told me that
they thought it was supposed to be Spike
the foreman since he wore sunglasses was
slightly older and bullied Luigi and
this is plausible since there are plenty
of examples of kids being blonde when
they're young and getting dark hair as
they grow up but I think in this medium
if they Med for it to be Spike they
would have just given him dark hair you
know but to be honest I'm not 100
satisfied with any of these answers
what's the 10 any shirt it's so specific
anyway all I know is that the pin on his
backpack looks like a dizzy dial so
there and thank you to betterhelp for
sponsoring this video here at new
rockstars we like to figure out what
makes movies work go frame by frame to
really figure out what's going on but
when we need Insight on what's going on
with ourselves we use better help better
help is the world's largest therapy
service and it's 100 online with better
help you can tap into a network of over
30 000 licensed and experienced
therapists who can help you with a wide
range of issues to get started just
answer a few questions about what you're
looking for from therapy and what your
preferences are better help will then
match you with a therapist from their
Network that's right for you after that
talk to your therapist however you feel
comfortable whether it's via text chat
phone or video call you can message your
therapist at any time and schedule live
sessions when it's convenient for you if
your therapist isn't the right fit for
any reason you can switch to a new
therapist at no additional charge
betterhelp gives you the same level of
professionalism and quality you can
expect from in-office therapy but with a
therapist who's custom picked for you
more scheduling flexibility and at a
more affordable price get 10 off your
first month at betterhelp.com new
rockstars that's
[Music]
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p.com Slash new
rockstars for 10 off your first month of
therapy this next one I'm honestly not
really sure how this happened but my
mention of the wands in the antique shop
accidentally got cut but they're there
along with these secret eggplants that
I'm still convinced are just that can't
get one past me Nintendo I can see an
eggplant from a mile away a doink and
then this one's on me but while we
pointed out the star design in the
railing of Peach's Courtyard I somehow
missed the mushroom designs until this
last watch through and Toad cooking to
distract the guards might be a hint that
he might eventually be the captain Toad
since Captain Toad Cooks even though
this dish is much more breath of the
wild to me during the travel Montage
Mario Chomps on an Apple when walking
through what I'm stubbornly calling
Yoshi's Island and this Yoshi licks
their lips a reference to Apples being
the fruit that Yoshi originally ate in
Super Mario World not so much
button Princess Peach's flashback we can
see that she didn't come out of the same
pipe as Mario did which doesn't
necessarily mean that she didn't come
from the same world as him but it is
interesting checking in on the big bad
of the movie we had it in writing the
last breakdown but I just thought I'd
say it with my human voice that Bowser's
piano says the Ludwig von Koopa the name
of one of the Koopa kids and also a play
on the composer and pianist Ludwig von
Beethoven and as as he sings peaches at
the piano several images of peach appear
that are reminiscent of Peach's ultimate
Smash in the Super Smash Bros games now
this made it into a trailer breakdown
but not the movie breakdown but the
statues that Bowser has of himself
everywhere are classic Bowser as statues
of himself are seen in several of the
Mario games let's talk DK I knew that so
many things were hidden in this high
speed Kart scene and going through it
frame by frame this is the case firstly
although we see Chunky Kong in the
stadium scene we also can see him in the
background during this part Swanky Kong
who is in the poster but notably missing
from the stadium scene in the actual
movie is actually the one who gets hit
by the banana that the blonde Kong
throws him being sansad really threw me
off finally there's a cute no Bullet
Bill sign that's a Mario Kart not when
you turn into a giant Bullet Bill
hitting people out of the way in the
stadium aside from all of the smash
moves Donkey Kong throws barrels at
Mario a throwback to the original Donkey
Kong arcade game and the mini mushroom
and super Bell are both power-ups that
are in the games originating at least
specifically how they appear in the
movie from new Super Mario Bros and
Super Mario 3D World respectively in the
stands the DK banners have 8-bit Donkey
Kongs on them there's a Kong with an N
on their hat and a Kong with a 64 on
their shirt together making N64 and
Diddy Kong plays Bongos in celebration
like in Donkey konga last little Kong
things to point out are that Dory and a
or V mare both appear on the map in
Cranky's cabin and in the card Factory
the workers have patches of the Banana
Cup symbol from the Mario Kart Series
yeah lied one more Kong thing when
they're arguing in the Monterey about
Donkey Kong being just a smash monkey
this is possibly a reference to the
monkey smash game mode in Donkey Kong
64. another section that moves really
quickly is Peach and Toad heading back
through town during this part there are
street signs that point to Peach's
castle and the toad shop slash houses a
sign saying what people can find in the
blue mushroom sector which consists of
the Super Mario Bros 3 chess likely
representing the ATMs chops and pipes
and one of the shops has boomerangs and
pal blocks like the antique shop but
also has super pickaxes from Captain
Toad treasure Tracker and Boots either
meant to reference the gum a shoe item
originally from Super Mario Bros 3 or
maybe the boots you get in Paper Mario
and we talked about the paintings in the
castle previously but in this section we
specifically see Toadette in one of them
fast forward to the wedding scene and
one of the things I love happening in
the background is a piranha plant
hungrily looking at a Goomba and the
Goomba absolutely sweating right now
considering this piranha plant's habits
of putting things in its mouth that we
see throughout the movie there's also a
heart-shaped wedding arbor that is
reminiscent of the cake topper used in
Mario Odyssey and on the gift table
there's a green and yellow present just
like the opening of new Super Mario Bros
when trout they're sticking with that I
love is the Snippets and shy guys being
cowards as you can see one hiding behind
a tree when Mario and DK are fighting
and some hiding behind pews and Ice
while Peach is kicking booty when Bowser
launches the bomber bill at the castle
many fans were reminded of Super Smash
Bros melee where periodically on
Princess Peach's castle level a bonsai
bill will hit the castle causing a large
explosion then we make it back to
Brooklyn and let's go ahead and call out
all the buildings and whatnot that we
didn't get to last time a tour of
Mario's block if you will punch out
Pizzeria is located on Brooklyn Street
and shops around the block include
blizzard pop ice cream with a polar bear
from Ice Climbers blizzard being one of
the ice climber special moves in Super
Smash Bros a donut shop perhaps
referencing the donut block from Super
Mario Bros 3 or maybe donut planes from
Super Mario World gyro Mart referencing
NES game gyromite with an icon of Rob a
medical office with capsules from Dr
Mario on a sign Stack Up shoe Center
referencing NES game stack up something
7 Clinic let me know in the comments if
you can tell what that first word's
supposed to be because I can't make it
out City bike with an excite bike icon
on the sign a big Enterprise building a
soda popinski sign that along with an ad
on the building that says popinski is
referencing the punch out character of
the same name and a card shop with a
picture of the hanafuna playing cards
themselves and a fuzzy originally from
Super Mario World when Bowser is
attacking Mario we can see that one of
the cars has a license plate that says
bnq 1925. now this license plate number
can also be seen in several pieces of
media including minions the rise of Gru
episode 1 of DreamWorks spooky stories
and a few procedural crime dramas this
is because Hollywood has a short list of
license plates that aren't in use in the
real world and bnq 1925 is one for New
York which is kind of nifty how even in
an animated movie they used a New York
specific one for a car in Brooklyn the
shy guy jumping on Spike at the end
reminds me of the shy guys harassing
villagers in Super Mario RPG and no I
will never let go of the dream that
they'll one day acknowledge that game
again later that day
and Bowser being bottled up is not
unlike the ending credits of Super Mario
3D World Luigi gets his moment in the
Sun as he hits his finger guns Victory
pose that originated from Super Smash
Bros melee as he's jumping into the pipe
at the end and the after credits scene
with the Yoshi gives me some major
Jurassic Park slash World Vibes with the
eggs slowly breaking and those are
those are supposed Super Mario Brothers
movie if you watched without somehow
watching the original breakdown that's
insane please go watch that one too
which has every other Easter egg we
found meanwhile you can follow me on
Twitter at it'sianavanston follow And
subscribe to new rockstars at new
rockstars and here Bell so you can be
notified when we have more breakdowns of
everything you love and hey
debates or reactions to the titles you
can't get enough of be sure to subscribe
to our live Channel thebreak room
bye-bye that's my best Mario I'll go
practice
[Music]